you mentioned in one of your talks that
most spiritual teachers for lack of a
better word emphasize awakening and then
you said well what are you talking about
most people should feel compassion and
love and security
and to me this is an important point
it's one that i mentioned on not me this
but it's one that came up on a previous
episode with carl fristen and you seem
to be one of the teachers that i see
emphasize this or at least bring it up
though you don't call it this but this
notion of path dependence in physics
which is that it's not about this
destination the destination also depends
on where you are and then how you're
going to get to it in the condition of
the world so to make a blanket statement
and say one should be enlightened and so
on and i see this perhaps you do too
maybe you don't but i see this in
different comment sections of different
videos and online
with people saying you're already lost
if you are in the scientific mindset
you've already lost or you will never
realize x until you follow some path
that i'm telling you and
when i read that
it's not as if it's directed to me i'm
seeing it on other sites but when i read
that i see that as
a spiritual form of
it's like spiritual superciliousness or
arrogance where they and it also puts
undue pressure on people
to
to
perhaps perhaps one should accept
the the position other people are and
i i think you i agree with you okay but
i think you it may some of those stories
are taken out of context
meaning
saying you're lost
and
you're not getting it
it is a methodology methodology it is
when a teacher tongue to a student
interact with a students
to have an impact on them in a certain
way sometimes you have to say that
but not for everybody
you see it's not i wouldn't say that
about somebody who's not my student none
of my business i don't know whether
obviously but if one of my students is
sort of says come to me and say i want
to learn this but then they don't do it
they do something else or they go off on
some kind of tangent i'll tell them
you see you know you're lost you don't
know what you're doing
you're wasting your life
you see
and that would make an impact and make
them then
recommit
to the what they said they wanted
i see the way that you're describing it
is a much more compassionate loving
amiable approach than some of what i see
and i'm not and you're not this i'm just
saying that this is some of what i see
with people adamantly claiming it
exclamation points as if they're
fearfully commenting about how one
should never feel fear and there's a bit
of derision in it too there's a bit of
yeah oh look at you you little oh little
one you have no idea and i'm the one
that understands this and if you only
could see it from my point of view
there's a bit of condescension in that i
don't think i don't think the buddha
would have talked like that
you know but i agree with you there are
people who talk like that but that's
you see to be spiritually realized
you're naturally compassionate and
loving
and compassion and
includes attunement
appropriateness
can you expand other attunement i mean
attunement means
i relate to a human being depending on
who and where they are what they are
what they're into what their interests
with their orientation i'm not you know
i'm attuned to it and i speak to that i
i don't just lay on my value system on
them
and that
if somebody doesn't express themselves
that way
i will question their realization
great this is something that i've
wondered too because it's difficult for
me as someone who's being introduced to
this in many ways to discern who is
enlightened from who is not and what
that word means and one of the rules of
thumb or the litmus tests that i use i
encourage people to send me their
theories of everything that's the name
of the channel
and
one of the reasons is i don't know what
is true so let me see even what is
ordinarily considered to be fringe or
woo
perhaps it's not because today's science
was 100 years ago
and so on though i see sometimes people
they're not as humble and tentative as i
believe that they should be when they're
presenting their toe for example their
their spiritual theory of everything you
see yeah
the way i understand spiritualization
the spiritual realization if somebody
has realized
their expression in the world
should come through what's called the
virtues
the you know the ending grounding
which is like humility
serenity
courage
you know
um
love
things like that
if somebody doesn't express themselves
that way what are they expressing you
know
so then is that okay when i am trying to
make a quick assessment because there
are probably 1 000 theories of
everything and it's difficult when each
person is putting up their hand saying i
have veto you have no idea i have vita
you don't understand i can't even be
wrong is one of the ways that i could
perform a cursory yes or no to
investigate further is if are they being
inimical and boisterous and pushing it
and if so perhaps that's that implies a
bit of attachment and fear and maybe
they lack an understanding of how to
come across lovingly if one has to
thrust one's toe then
it's it's a different stage you see we
haven't gone to all the stages yet there
is a realization after realization there
is what i call actualization
actualization is what you
ends up being in wisdom actualization
mean you live what you realized you
don't just experience it
that is another stage of development
that doesn't automatically happen
through awakening and realization
earlier when we were talking about
wisdom i would have equated wisdom and
that definition of actualization so are
those two different in your mind
yeah i i agree with you they are similar
thing yes
so that's interesting because to me i've
seen wise people who wouldn't claim to
have any of these insights so that means
that one can be wise without being
realized and one could be realized
without being wise and at least for me
as this creature who's still perhaps
asleep i tend to prefer the wise i tend
to prefer the wise just because the wise
they're more loving i heed their message
you seem extremely wise and i don't know
am i wrong to prefer that [ __ ] or should
i have no preference with regard to this
it's just it's so difficult for me to
tell which messages are correct the
dalai lama to me exudes compassion and
serenity yes and he is humble too
right saying i'm still practicing i'm
still learning
yes he's not commenting with
yeah within a moderate use of
capitalization
you know
he doesn't do that you know that's
that's that's the real wisdom
that's why i like roger penrose you like
you know i like it right yes
his relationship to his theories is like
that
like his he talked about his theory of
consciousness as you know
he had his theory of consciousness with
that he has developed our microtubules
and all that but then he
says well
will you say that this is really the
truth he'll say well no i think we are
very far away from knowing what
consciousness is
so he sees it as
his contribution toward going that way
he doesn't see that's it while many
other people have fear of consciousness
they think that's it
i remember meeting you know one time
with several scientists
and neuroscientists who each one had
their theory of consciousness one of the
major theories of consciousness
and it had you know
we had some kind of conference whatever
but at some point we met
privately
and we were trying to say how we're
going to communicate those
field consciousness and make them more
accept acceptable to
larger scientific community
and i remember discussing it with them
and
and one of my ideas that each one has a
theory and very different you know
and we're all good
and and i said well you know to really
the scientific community because it's a
consensus kind of science that we have
and
you
you you can't just
give a big theory with all kind of
assumption and all kind of unknown thing
and expect a scientific community to
adopt it easily i said why not just give
a little thing at a time you know
even put one thing in a small thing and
see how people respond if it is more
accepted then you can add more
they all refused
they said no i want to put out my theory
everybody wanted their theory to be it
because
so part of it is hobros part of what i
think is sort of arrogance as you say
but part was apparently human nature
probably is like i want to be right you
know
each one is convinced that they're right
that's why i say i like project penrose
he's not convinced he's right
he knows he's an approximation
many of the others don't believe that
they think they got it
i find many of the people who we were
talking about earlier who with a
megaphone shout their toe out to other
people
in such a manner that doesn't have
people welcoming their toe they tend to
have in common that their insights were
precipitated by their private use of
psychedelics so do you see that
psychedelics to inform one's philosophy
or ontology etc as removed from a
community is somehow
net negative in some manner or not as
pure
well it's not that you know it's more
like
comparing my experiences from the 60s
and 70s on psychedelics
from my later experiences which happens
more spontaneously
there is a difference in quality it's
not the same
the psychedelic gives it the changes
thing some way
that is
not how reality is exactly
when you experience
you know
one raw consciousness
and and
it it has a possibility for opening up
but it also opens up to other things
that are not true you know because also
can magnify our imagination
and that's why people have bad trips you
know
because it could magnify anything
so um
i the way i think about it is that
some traditions
like the ayahuasca tradition in south
america for instance
they have developed a way of working
with it
that they use it for you know
as part of their spiritual spiritual
practice but i also seen some
americans who went there and
did that and they came back and their
spiritual access naturally was
got more narrow
hmm interesting see that goes back to
what i was referring to earlier about
path dependence so some people would say
no this lesson works and it works
ubiquitously but it also depends on
where you are one of the ways that i
like to conceptualize this i'm curious
if you i'm curious what your thoughts
are
is that i see some westerners taking on
eastern approaches and vice versa
somewhat uncritically and i wonder if
that's always a net benefit because to
me it's akin to installing max off force
installing mac software on your pc
you're going to get errors if it's not
compatible with how you grew up with
what your view is right now do you see
that i think there is a point there
current
in the sense that the
uh the eastern approach they have their
own world view
which is different from a western world
world view
for instance
um
both the indian spirituality and
buddhist spirituality
developed on being
free from samsara
right by the kosamsara which is the
ordinary world
and basically
because they believe in reincarnation
is that the idea is to not reincarnate
again
this is not just
you want to be enlightened so they'll be
free from this world and not come back
again
and and the west we don't subscribe to
that kind of thing you know
incarnation coming back or whatever you
know for me
i don't know if that's true or not
see so i don't look at spirituality that
way
i i look at spirituality that is to
make life as complete as deep as
possible
and that means something else for later
right
see and so so
yeah so some people
adopt the eastern view of with all the
their philosophical or uh
metaphysical perspective of
reincarnation
and
and
you know and
leaving the world and
which which has in it a way of saying
that this world is
is no good that's you're here
you see
i
myself
i don't know i mean i'm i don't know i
mean i i have some experiences about
incarnation whatever i don't know if
they're true or not
if they're real or not
and so i don't subscribe to that
so it's true if somebody who's watching
who takes on that like they're putting a
hat on
their brain
that
is just a hat on them it's not really
naturally
arisen inside within them
but spiritual but however if somebody
takes the spiritual tradition
and take the practices and learn to
connect to the truth of who they are and
then that is independent of the world of
you
because you just what you are at this
moment
what you are at this moment has nothing
to do with the past or the future so
you're not thinking of
all the
you're free of the world of you
basically any world of view
that way it could be useful yes and many
i think have found it useful that way